et maintenant j'accueille jerry lewis
cls bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue cole
harbour gagnant oui les minecraftiens
assez votre interprète oui d'actes
d'accord jerry lewis
acteurs réalisateurs inventeur du
téléthon merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle
est ce que vous êtes content d'être à
paris à la maison mon deuxième foyer
alors vous dit jerry lewis quand je suis
aux usa et que je commence accapare des
la seule chose qui me remonte le moral
c'est de prendre un avion et d'aller à
paris comme down
quand je deviens un as get free run et
que je suis dépressif iron air france
air from two paris et bien paris merci
jerry lewis signalons henri leconte et
lycées tennis tennis payer ce que ces
dix meilleurs big ten espère annoncer
une grande les 45 guy henry à roland
garros
la langue sont alors d'y aller lewis en
france vous êtes une star depuis les
années 60 que vous étiez encensé par la
critique la critique intellos des
cahiers du cinéma et de la revue positif
c'est pareil en europe c'est pareil au
japon c'est pareil en australie comment
expliquez vous vous soyez moins aimé aux
usa que dans le reste du monde
vicois qui ne sont pas intelligents à
l'algérie vous aimez beaucoup la france
la france vous aime beaucoup mais que
pensez vous de la position française sur
la guerre en irak à itunes à get into
pas manquer il ne parle jamais de
politique
micro sera aidé ou chrome lui aurait dit
et fait déjà de la comédie c'est pas la
peine d'en faire plus de coeur
itunes 9 bis as many as bouche alors
vous avez donné beaucoup de plaisir au
cinéma jerry lewis et en ce qui me
concerne avec docteur jerry et mister
love il ya c'est extraordinaire
quand il est transformé et qui sort et
que on le voit pas nous on voit les gens
qui le regarde et on sait pas quelle
tête fila c'est la première fois que moi
j'ai pris conscience de ce qui était la
réalisation au cinéma dit notre place
was my life enveloppe oui c'était sa
façon de montrer l'amour qu'ils avaient
from d'amour tout vient de frapper la
machine mais tout est de damas ci
dessous du héros faire tout en vous nous
avez donné également beaucoup de plaisir
dans le film avec robert de niro le film
de martin scorsese et qui s'appelle la
valse des pantins kings of comedy bien
sûr mais ce qu'on savait pas c'est que
vous souffriez le martyre hier pendant
37 ans tous les jours vous avez souffert
pendant 37 ans ouais
la timide où nous sommes stupides faut
ni poésie physique al ain et nect de
coaching comme down to mène à tout et me
to back to my du racing voilà ce qu'il
dit c'est que quand il était sur scène
pendant deux heures ils avaient
l'adrénaline qui lui donnait de
l'énergie
mais dès que le rideau tombe et il avait
besoin de deux personnes pour le ramener
dans sa loge
oui oui alors c'est dû au fait que vous
faisiez vos cascades vous même aux us
airways toujours le mois oui mais voila
voila et est la spécialité de jerry
lewis était de tomber de sa hauteur du
piano man toujours sur sa colonne
vertébrale
voilà alors on va regarder quelques
chutes
gic jerry lewis